welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Sultan Sood Al Qasimi he is at Yale
as a visiting scholar in the Middle East
Studies Council and is teaching a course
on the politics of modern Middle Eastern
art Mr Al Qasimi is a columnist and
researcher on social political and
cultural affairs in the Arab Gulf states
he is also the founder of the barge eel
Art Foundation today we'll talk with Mr
Al Qasimi
about modern Middle Eastern art and
architecture welcome Sultan thank you
let's start with talking about the
course you're teaching here what are you
teaching the students well as you said
the New York production I'm teaching a
class on the politics of modern Middle
Eastern art we look at the 20th and the
21st century across the Middle East so
we looked at North Africa so we look at
the Arab world Egypt Syria Iraq all the
way to Morocco the Gulf states but we
also look at Israel Iran and Turkey and
we try and study the intersection of art
and politics how artists reacted to
major political events wars revolutions
but also to social movement moving women
emancipation movement labor movements
and whatnot and so we we try and study
this region through an artistic lens
where as it's been always studied
through a political lens okay and what
years are you looking at I know it's
modern but what does that mean in terms
of we really look at the early 20th
century there was a major event that
took place around 1906 where there was a
religious decree that said that art is
okay and art is allowed and it's no
longer forbidden and so you have the
advent of the first university that
teaches art in a systemic system in
Egypt in Cairo in early 20th century so
we almost take that as our starting
point and we go all the way to the Arab
Spring and well into the 21st century
okay so I would venture a guess that
most Westerners do
know much about modern Middle Eastern
art so what are some of the things that
you might point out as differences or
maybe even similarities that we wouldn't
be aware of I would say that most Middle
Easterners aren't aware of modern Middle
East or not it's such a a new
scholarship and the new you know the
space that we're still exploring it
people are surprised what I tell them
after 15 or 20 years of reading and
exploring Middle Eastern art that I
don't know about a certain artist
actually it makes me happy to discover
that there's so much that I do not know
and so I would say that a lot of people
aren't aware how active the women's
artists movement was throughout the
Middle East all the way back to the
early 20th century a lot of people
aren't aware of the ethnic minorities
religious minorities Jewish artists
Christian artists minorities ethnic
minorities how active they were and all
the cross-cultural exchange that the
region has had with South Asia India
with Africa sub-saharan Africa with the
Mediterranean Basin the Caucasus and so
it is such an eclectic part of the world
the people I think would really be you
know positively surprised to find out
how how varied it is and in terms of the
art itself is it paintings as well as
sculpture it runs the whole gamut yes oh
we do look at painting sculpture but
also film we look at photography poetry
there's so much to think of but of
course I have to I have to emphasize
that we're just touching upon these
subjects rather than really delving deep
into them okay and you recently created
an art foundation the bar geo Art
Foundation I'll talk a little bit about
that why you thought it was necessary to
establish it so I had been collecting
art since 2002 so it's a it's almost 17
years now and I always wanted to have a
home
and so I started collecting art and and
I lobbied my local government back home
in the emirate that I come from and they
had given me a space for a good eight
year period and now the works are on
long term display the Sharjah Art Museum
and Sharjah is the emirate in the UAE
where I come from and it's a beautiful
Museum dating back to the 1990s and they
have been very very generous with giving
me the space so that we can have a
long-term display and this is a
challenge Marilyn that we face in the
Arab world where middle-eastern art
isn't really on put on long-term display
we really suffer from this it should
called short-term exhibitions which is
wonderful but in reality you don't have
a chance to develop a long-term
relationship think of yourself when you
go when you went with maybe your parents
or your family to visit a museum
exhibition maybe at the MoMA and then
you go maybe you take your kids or you
take your nephews or your nieces and
then so it's a generational relationship
we don't have this in the Middle East
and so that's what I'm trying to do
right right you know in fact you
mentioned the MoMA I recently went there
with my daughter and I was very
surprised as part of one of their
exhibits they did have modern Middle
Eastern art exhibited there have you
seen that yes and they have a little
note about why it's so important to show
this art so I understand your point on
that precisely so how many how big how
many paintings are exhibited in the
museum oh right now the long-term
display at the Sharjah museum has about
a hundred and forty works although we
are now launching a few short-term
exhibitions coming here to the US and so
some of the works would be leaving the
museum and they will be exchanged over
the next year or so very good very good
and you mentioned your hometown and I
know you're working on a book project
about its architecture so let's talk up
a little bit about that and why it's so
important to you to to recognize this
architecture so I'm really interested in
modernism I'm interested in
documenting and archiving the near
history rather than the ancient history
1950s 60s 70s not only in art but also
in architecture and other you know and
in other sort of fields of culture and
so I noticed that the cultural heritage
the architectural heritage of Sharjah
and the UAE isn't documented that a lot
of the buildings that were designed by
American architects like the architects
collaborative a firm that was founded
here in the u.s. in the 1940s by Walter
Gropius designed a building actually a
number of buildings across the Gulf in
Sharjah these buildings have never been
documented properly and so these are
important world heritage sites
I believe dating back to half a century
then deserve to be documented some of
them are being knocked down Marilyn
unfortunately and this is something that
we see in major cities around the world
this challenge of identifying which
building is worthy of saving and which
building you know you just have to let
go of and so for me I rather than try to
champion the preservation only of these
buildings at least we try to get them
documented for future generations
are there any characteristics of the
architecture that are similar oh so a
lot of these architects that came to the
UAE this is before the UAE was founded
as a country in 1971 they came in the
1950s and 60s and they came in from
Europe from North America they came in
from across the Middle East but also
from South Asia and they had to adapt to
the in the environment and the
environment is hot the environment is a
humid the environment is dry and so the
architecture had to adapt and also the
fact that the material wasn't readily
available you just don't have access to
concrete and cement so what you have to
build with is you reuse a lot of wood
and I that was something that was so
interesting for me that doors would be
removed from houses and then reused in
other houses that you see the material
that has more than one life span and I
see this is something that was so
interesting
a gate that was designed for a house is
now being used in building and so that
was I thought were quite quite
interesting for the mid 20th century
down there right right because today
that's kind of on point it's a trend for
sustainability reasons to reuse some
products that's right yeah and then
lastly I know you just launched a
competition an architecture competition
so talk a little bit about that
so we I've come to an agreement with
this major architectural award and they
heard me complain about you know the
lack of opportunity for for me to having
to have a museum that is permanent for
the collection right because I always
consider the collection to be public I
always consider myself to be an
administrator of a collection I never
say this art belongs to me because I
feel like you know whatever long my
lifespan is I really hope this life that
this this work lives for generations and
maybe hopefully centuries ahead and so I
my dream was to build a you know a
structure that houses the this
collection and so we just decided to
launch this competition it doesn't mean
I have the money to build the museum but
I wanted to get the public interested in
this idea and it's only been it's only
been launched recently but so far the
feedback has been very positive because
I'm calling on people to look at the
entire region and draw inspiration from
North Africa from the Levant from the
Gulf from Western from the entire region
when they propose an architectural
landmark that houses this collection is
there something that you particularly
would like to see incorporated into the
design let me would that be you know a
spoiler alert there's a spoiler alert
but the last glass the better okay cuz I
you know I also think of the environment
and I don't like the idea of these glass
houses that are being built in the Gulf
there's there's too much use of glass
and I'd like us to look back into what
we talked about a few minutes ago about
environmental consciousness about being
aware of the environment of these cities
at least you know this region's that we
inhabit and hopefully have a building
that's not just an architectural
landmark
but also you know a building that we can
look forward to in the future and say
this was a building that took the
environment into consideration right
well we will look forward to seeing the
outcome of that competition hopefully in
the near future thank you so much for
being here with us today thank you for
having me Marlon for more information
about Mr Al Qasimi please visit our
website at macmillan report yeah edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
thank you very much thank you for having
me
you